hey everybody I'm Daniel Dae Kim I'm
here at BuzzFeed and I am about to read
your thirst tweets here we go I was just
uh I was just hearing a lot about these
there's tweets and now I'm about to
experience it myself here we go first
one I don't want remember why but I do
remember that Daniel Dae Kim was like
hugging to get of me in my dream last
night just like non-stop
that's pretty g-rated considering so I'm
really happy about that I'm glad we
started with that one thank you very
much Laura I don't even know what this
one means but I read it I saw a picture
of Daniel Dae Kim and my ass just
cleaned fell off what does that mean oh
it could be a good thing like it to be
separated from your ass I don't want to
get into it Daniel Dae Kim can break my
heart and I thank him and ask him to do
it all over again I have really sweet
fan this is really sweet and I would
really not want to break your heart I
promise
OMG I think I need to call my
maintenance crew for a mop for my drool
I love you Daniel Dae Kim it's not the
greatest image but thanks for ever
wanting to sit on Daniel Dae Kim face
now we're talking now we're getting
somewhere
gosh it's early in the morning isn't it
I think so
I hope so yeah cuz sitting on your face
in a bad way and I could make good money
that could be very bad show there should
be more shots of Daniel Dae Kim s ass in
those jeans
every episode please I sense a theme
here there's a lot of ass stuff
happening Daniel Dae Kim more like daddy
damn am i right folks
holds up hands for high five here we go
I'm starting to sweat
alright here we go Daniel Dae Kim
cheekbones can choke me to death I don't
even know how that would work but thank
you choke you to death um I shouldn't
think too much about all right are they
really
it's very nice they look natural don't
they can you even imagine not giving
Daniel Dae Kim whatever he wants Jesus
look at him well and thank you for
bringing Jesus into it Daniel Dae Kim is
just walking sex okay I didn't know
anyone was arguing with you but but okay
I cannot believe I slept on Daniel Dae
Kim my whole life
what a hot fine-ass man and if you read
it a different way it says what a hot
fine-ass man which would also be correct
all right Daniel Dae Kim has an amazing
ass hashtag just saying that's like the
fifth ass one Daniel Dae Kim more like
Daniel Baek him he is one talented
fine-ass man I'm telling you I've never
thought so much about my backside in my
life and finally Daniel Dae Kim excuse
me while I lick my TV screen what are
you watching
these have been fun thanks guys I think
we've emptied out the barrel so I hope
your thirst has been quenched I feel
like they're watching the wrong side of
me for the most part but thanks thanks
everyone
like I feel much better about myself
thanks BuzzFeed this has been a lot of
fun I'm here actually in New York
because a movie that I'm in is
premiering tomorrow night it's called
Hellboy and it opens nationwide April
12th hope you'll check it out
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]